So, having this much rain is rare for this time of the year?
Yes, I'm afraid that you guys have been a bit unlucky with the weather here so far.
That's okay, a little bit of rain never hurts.
That's true. Speaking of which, in Venezuela we have a saying, "No rain, no rainbows."
Hey, I like that!
People tend to forget that rain is really a necessity for life.
Hey guys, not to change the subject, but are we still planning to catch a movie tonight?
Yes, definitely.
In fact, there's a new Bruce Willis movie now that I want to see.
By the way, do you like Bruce Willis? I like him, too.
He's one of my favorite actors.
Yeah, he is tough and funny.
That's true, but I like him because he's hot.